vamos a evaluar la integral definida de
menos 3 a 5 de 4 de x los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta para resolver esto
tenemos que recordar el teorema
fundamental del cálculo que relaciona la
noción de una integral definida y una
anti derivada el teorema fundamental del
cálculo nos dice que la integral
definida de a ave de fx de x va a ser
igual a la andi derivada de nuestra
función efe que denotamos con la f
mayúscula evaluada en el límite integral
superior b menos la anti derivada de f
evaluada en el límite integral inferior
a esto es lo que tenemos que hacer aquí
cuál es la anti derivada de 4 quizá
ustedes digan que es igual a 4x también
pueden pensar en esto en términos de la
regla de la potencia ya que 4 es igual a
4 por x a la 0 por lo que incrementamos
el cero en uno y dividimos todo esto
entre 1 lo que nos da igual a 4 x la
anti derivada nos da 4x
podemos decir que esto es nuestra efe
mayúscula de equis y la vamos a evaluar
en 5 y en menos 3 para encontrar la
diferencia entre ellas lo que resultó
aquí al evaluar la anti derivada en el
límite integral superior es cuatro por
cinco y a esto le restamos nuestra anti
derivada evaluada en el límite inferior
que es 4 x menos 3 esto es 20 menos 12
negativos lo que será más 12 y nos queda
20 más 12 igual a 32 hagamos otro
ejemplo en donde apliquemos la inversa
de la regla de la potencia queremos
encontrar la integral definida que va de
menos 1 a 3 de 7 x al cuadrado px que va
a ser igual esto queremos encontrar la
anti derivada de esto sí esto es efe
minúscula de x cuál será f mayúscula de
x el inverso de la regla de la potencia
incrementa en 1 este exponente por lo
que nos queda 7 por x al cubo y lo
dividimos entre este exponente
incrementado 3
esto queremos evaluarlo en el límite
superior y a esto restarle la evaluación
en el límite inferior esto va a ser
igual a la evaluación en el límite
superior es 7 por 3 al cubo entre 3 y a
esto le restamos la evaluación de la
anti derivada o la f mayúscula en el
límite inferior que es 7 x menos 1 al
cubo entre 3 está primera expresión es 7
por 3 al cubo entre 3 va a ser lo mismo
que 7 por 9 lo que nos da 63 y por este
lado tenemos menos 1 al cubo igual a
menos 1 por 7 pero aquí estamos restando
un número negativo por lo que sumamos y
nos queda más 7 tercios
si queremos expresar esto como un número
mixto siete tercios es lo mismo que dos
y un tercio cuando lo sumamos nos queda
65 y un tercio y con esto terminamos